even when we were successful it was just
constant criticism it's now now let me
say this maybe there was a lot of Praise
but I didn't hear it because when you're
in that mindset you just hear the
criticism it's like if if somebody talks
to you for a minute and they say one
small critical thing and that's all you
remember about the conversation so that
may have been my life people may have
been told me how great I was every 5
seconds and I just didn't hear it but my
memory was like we would get on stage
and played to 15,000 people and and I'd
walk off stage and somebody would be
standing backstage saying you shouldn't
have done that and you shouldn't have
done this and people are mad and you're
such an idiot and that's what I remember